Bonjour,
et bon retour.
Merci de me rejoindre aujourd'hui.
Passons au sujet...
en vous montrant les couleurs
nécessaires pour peindre avec moi.
J'ai ma toile basique.
Mouillée et prête.
Ok, prenons notre fidèle pinceau large.
On agite le barreau.
Tout est dans le poignet.
On met une touche de "Jaune Neige"
On va le mixer un peu avec...
le "Blanc Laiteux".
Maintenant..
Dansons comme dans un petit ciel heureux.
Souvenez-vous...
C'est votre univers, vous êtes libres de créer
et de briser les règles.
Oh mon Dieu...
J'aimerais me rouler...
dans toute cette poudreuse blanche.
Planer avec cette beauté.
Mon Dieu, j'adore la drogue.
Vraiment beaucoup.
Je suis complètement défoncé.
Peignons de petits arbres heureux ici.
Aucun problème à être amis avec des arbres...
Ce que je vous déconseille, c'est de manger cette peinture.
Faites-moi confiance.
OK, il est temps de s'agiter le pinceau à nouveau.
Voilà. Ça fait du bien.
Regardez-moi ça.
On dirait que notre peinture est terminée.
Évitez de tâcher votre pantalon.
Et n'oubliez pas que la drogue c'est mal.